so for seven days with the girls and hey
I'm over you yeah like I'm talking like
somewhere where you really really take
yourself out of your current lifestyle
your daily routine and then you can
evaluate and obviously there is no time
on healing healing probably takes years
and you'll never get over everything but
healing to a point then you don't
transfer it onto the next relationship
but I don't think you can not transfer
things to another you can't no you you
if you take enough time I feel like you
can you can but there's always going to
be things that may trigger you and it's
up to you I don't I I genuinely think
that there's some things that your
partner might do that will prompt a
random response
you didn't even know that you had and
that's the moment you you take a step
back and you're like okay I haven't
dealt with this I'm going to revisit
that but also take the time and be
courteous enough to inform your partner
like Hey listen if you guys haven't had
that conversation
this is what I dealt with please bear
with me it will not happen again if you
see it does let me know feel comfortable
to let me know so I I really think that
healing is something that can take place
also in a relationship but you have had
to have done the bulk of the work for
yourself do you think that healing needs
to have therapy so there's some tangible
result because it's like if you're just
talking to your friends like they're
more likely to tell you what you want to
hear where a therapist will like sit you
down and tell you about yourself
and I'm currently doing therapy right
now and at first I was just like this is
like what white people do like no
literally because no no no
this is this is literally my thought
process and even all the people around
me when I finally told them I'm going to
do therapy they're like what are you
doing therapy for that's like white
people stuff it completely changed my
life like completely the first thing I
realized was there's a lot of internal
dialogue that I have going on in myself
and I have an expectation that the
people who are closest to me should be
able to gauge accurately how I feel
because I intuitively am able to like
know when something is wrong with the
people who are closest to me so I always
felt that there wasn't a balance of
skills let's say so having that
conversation is not just about oh how do
you feel they really untangled the
mental mess that's in your mind and lay
everything straight in front of you to
allow you to deal with it so it's a life
skill that you can take anywhere the
workplace friendships like so yeah they
start from the beginning someone said
women tend to use words to grandiose
their predicament toxic healing trauma I
was always good to say so when you were
saying that you kind of um you know this
healing thing and going on vacation
vacation Etc to my mind from my
experience because because I've I've
been with women who are kind of healing
and it just seems to me that they're
they're waiting for an emotional
stimulus that has you know a greater
impact than their previous guy so so
women want to sleep up no no one heals
and gets with like a really nice guy who
treated their lives she gets with like a
child in Thailand and then she's like yo
[__] the last guy you know I can do
better I'm empowered then she comes back
and you know even the therapy thing I've
met a lot of crazy women who do therapy
yeah and most of the time when they tell
me about their thoughts on what they
think in therapy I just get a lot of
feminist rhetoric I I get a lot of like
using these words and this that to kind
of say things are actually quite simple
that is like
why do you expect people to know what
you think though because people well
some women like to be like to present
themselves as complex and deep and
especially when they're on their healing
Journey they want to come across as oh
I've done the work I'm now woke I'm very
aware of myself but then their actions
don't reflect what it is that they're
saying to me someone who is healing is
someone who I think like you said Amber
has actually taken time out so I'm going
to be really quick
November or December last year I cut
someone who was completely toxic off not
only did I cut him off I cut 98 of
people off and I'm talking extended
family like no one knew where Linda was
people on my social media if they see
this they'll be like yeah she
disappeared like it's only June that I
came back and even when before that even
when men were approaching me I would
tell them Point Blank I have gone
through something very like traumatizing
I need a time like to just deal with
myself and you're someone else's son I'm
not gonna put that on to you and 98 of
them was like well that's really honest
I respect you for that and some sort of
basic friendship or connection was
maintained now every day but like on my
socials you know what I mean okay I can
see your facial expressions you're like
what are you talking about but I'm very
like I know what I'm saying okay but so
cutting off 98 of people you say yeah do
you think do you think that's like
healthy especially it was healthy for me
because I'm a giver so because I'm
constant only someone who I used to have
a thing of
if someone did something I'd be like
but how do they feel if I react and pull
myself away from them rather than being
like no what you did something wrong I
love me enough to take a step back and
cut you off because you're now no longer
entitled to my presence so a lot of
people yeah my presence because I know
what I offer in every friendship in
every relationship in every Dynamic so I
had to realize that I need to take back
my energy
and just do me and it was the best thing
that I did for six months I've never
been so selfish in my life I think so
you healed by being selfish yes because
I'm a selfless person uh-huh like don't
you that kind of sounds like you would
have the opposite effect because because
you go to the next guy and say the last
six months I've been selfish date me no
that's not it because
I'm telling you I'm telling you how this
sounds tonight what did you do in your
six months I did indoor rock climbing I
went swimming I painted I started a
novel I started I did things for me so
it's funny Andrew Tate talks about this
how women will talk like they're the men
they want to date so like if we wanted
to date a guy those are things that like
we'd want to hear about and to hear that
he'd done but like the guys don't care
about that I wouldn't bring up unless
they asked okay but don't you think so
for example right so when I hear about
that Journey
um you said like the therapist made you
more accountable right that was like my
first therapist so I chose to do that
yeah okay but surely if you characterize
98 of your relationships are so toxic
that they're worthy of being caught off
at you know some some short notice
because
you are a giver which in my mind sounds
like you lack the self-control to
adequately manage healthy boundaries
then you know I'm not being rude but
that doesn't sound as much
accountability as a very complex way of
digging yourself up but that's part of
the journey not everyone's gonna get it
at that point so it took me two years
and a few more situations to realize
Linda you got a poor issue with
boundaries
you are not gonna if someone comes and
tells you you have an issue or if a girl
calls you about the same issue and you
get tired of her telling you about the
same issue you leave her alone and
hopefully if she self if she is someone
who is self-reflective over time you
hope that that person sits with themself
until they realize their own mess and
realize I need to change couldn't you
just say stop talking about this [__]
but that's for that person I can't speak
for them
I'm talking in relation to myself okay I
thought you were saying like you were
tired of listening no no no no that was
just a random example Oh I thought this
was no no
you seem like you have something else